or quelle journée splendide à sur l'île
aux enfants c'est vraiment tous les
jours le printemps
aujourd'hui j'ai très envie de faire un
jeu avec julie casimir bonjour ma très
chère amie coûte ce n'est pas le moment
de s'amuser à imiter monsieur 19 accusés
facteurs le facteur aux non je n'ai pas
vu pourquoi pour rien gare de moi mon
kiosque deux minutes je reviens tout de
suite je lis ou lalalalalala telle
catastrophe alors la journée commence
très mal
puis cette porte est trop petit toutou
ce kiosque est trop petit d'ailleurs auj
il est même minuscule je me demande
comment julie fait pour rentrer là
dedans
et elle ne m'a même pas dit bonjour
c'est incroyable on a tout pour être
heureux sur 7 il fait beau et mais non
au lieu de s'amuser ils ont toujours
quelque chose à faire
ah oui qu'est ce que je t'ai la porte et
le carton rouge ouvre un mois plus tôt
là à korhogo bon attend comme ça il
était temps que j'arrive j'ai cru que
j'allais faire tous tombés qu'est-ce que
ça ce sont des poupées pourquoi un
bonbon non c'était pas si je pourrai que
montrer ce sont des poufs et très belle
bon d'accord mais dis moi ta maison brin
caustique ce sont des poupées
folkloriques regardent ils sont en effet
très belle mais je voulais pas venir
comme françois n'est pas là nous allons
faire un jeu avec les enfants tu veux
bien ça fait une heure que je te le
demande a bouffé scud moi je n'en étais
pas aperçu main bien sûr tu parle
tellement ouais j'ai pratiquement rien
dit
excuse moi j'avais cru entendre quelques
mots
bon tu vas voir je vais prendre la carte
de france bien et je vais leur faire
deviner à quelle région appartiennent
ces poupées russes m - les poupées je
n'y connais rien du tout les enfants
manger tout ce jeu là et je vais faire
pas du tout ce joli vite voilà on m'a
donné vous venez vite la faire un jeu
voilà je vais vous montrer des poupées
de différentes régions de france et vous
allez essayer de trouver à quelle région
appartiennent ces poupées et me les
montre et sur la carte
alors voilà la première c'est quelle
région
c'est une niçoise nous parlait plus fort
et la région qui correspond vous savez
lui ce we sur la carte ces caniveaux
voilà c'est par là
une autre salle est difficile à trouver
celle là c'est une poupée du nord une
lilloise alors ça se situe ou dans la
carte de france c'est ça tout en haut
encore une autre celle là vous devriez
la trouver non ça vous dit rien avec une
coiffe comme ça c'est l'alsacienne il
c'est par là ensuite celle là c'est la
normande
et oui la normandie là tu peux me l'a
montré toi voilà voilà
ensuite comme une brute
voilà exactement c'était une botte celle
là voilà très vias et la bretonne et la
région qui correspond main très bien
voilà la bretagne pour des bottes
voilà c'est terminé alors maintenant
vous allez m'aider à les arranger dans
mon kiosque pour que ça fasse joly va
décrocher la carte
quelle honte à vous avez vu je ne sais
même pas occupé de moi elle ne parle
qu'en de ses poupées elle ne pense qu'à
ses poupées plus personne ne m'aime moi
qu'est-ce que je pourrais bien faire
pour que l'on s'occupe de moi j'ai une
idée
ouais voilà bien c'est ravissant mon
casque est une véritable petite
merveille grâce à vous on va être
l'année des camélias vous moquez de moi
mais que t'arrive-t-il pourquoi cette
idée disait aux poupées alsacienne mais
c'est ta faute chouly comme en a [ __ ]
mais oui tu ne t'intéresses est captée
poupées folkloriques tu ne t'occupes pas
de moi alors je me suis déguisé en
alsaciennes
pourquoi tu t'occupes de moi et je veux
m'occuper de toi qu'est-ce qui te ferait
plaisir et bien par exemple attend au
que tu me chante la chanson voilà
d'accord
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
[Musique]
je voudrais faire
li na
j'y vois d'ici les garçons
casimir show de sa chanson
françois
nouveau jeu
[Musique]
mais je l'aurais mieux pas si je vais à
fond mais j'aimerais mieux peu si
j'étais à l'enfant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le client que les [ __ ] et
ça y est
couleur cerise
m
[Musique]
à papillons passent un temps
à
dutil m
[Musique]
non
mais je m'en fais mieux peur si je
faisais la fin
mais je
si j'étais un enfant
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
art
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]